Shure: 6
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha
Alice:什么鬼
Alice: What the heck
Shure: 哈哈
Shure: Haha
Shure: 卧槽这个他妈的
Shure: Damn, this is freaking...
Shure: 哈哈
Shure: Haha
Shure: 跨肩膀肩膀跨
Shure: Cross shoulders, shoulders cross
Shure: 这几个关节好像2哒3哒45678 哇
Shure: These joints seem like 2, 3, 45678, wow
Lucia: 臀体拳预备
Lucia: Get ready for hip punches
Shure: 还扎马步
Shure: Even doing horse stance
Shure: 哇
Shure: Wow
Katrina: 哈
Katrina: Ha
Shure: 张元英转圈是吧
Shure: Zhang Yuanying spins, right?
Shure: 不行这真不会啊
Shure: No, I really can't do this
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha
Tasha: 难度不对吧
Tasha: Isn't this too difficult?
Shure: 这是0.5倍速是吗
Shure: Is this 0.5x speed?
Shure: 哈哈哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahahaha
Shure: one two three four
Shure: One two three four
Shure: one two three four 1234哇的fuck 23 哇吼
Shure: One two three four, 1234, wow fuck, 23, wow
Katrina: 哈
Katrina: Ha
Lucia: 哎好快这一边
Lucia: Hey, this side is so fast
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahaha
Lucia: 啊啊
Lucia: Ah ah
Shure: 不行了不行了
Shure: I can't, I can't
Katrina: 先把前两部分
Katrina: Let's start with the first two parts
Jake:再来一次
Jake: One more time
Shure: 再来
Shure: Again
Katrina: 把前两部分回顾一下
Katrina: Let's review the first two parts
Jake:来
Jake: Come on
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Yeah
Shure: 脑容量要炸了
Shure: My brain's gonna explode
Katrina: 手机呢调往前调一下
Katrina: Where's the phone, scroll it back a bit
Jake:放哪了
Jake: Where did we put it
Katrina: 你是要录我们刚刚跟音乐的吗
Katrina: Are you recording us with the music?
Katrina: 还是从头
Katrina: Or from the beginning
Jake:呃
Jake: Uh
Jake:就是你们来跳一次比较完整的就行
Jake: Just do a complete one for us
Shure: 那我们给大家展示一下这个第一部分
Shure: Then we'll show everyone the first part
Shure: 我们跳的最好的这一部分吧
Shure: The part we do best
Jake:全景相机
Jake: Panoramic camera
Jake:就是相当于这边处一人看你们
Jake: It's like having someone over here watching you
Shure: OK准备好了吗确定
Shure: OK, are you ready?
Shure: 二三四五六七八
Shure: Two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight
Shure: 二二三四五六七八
Shure: Two, two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight
Shure: 三二三四五六七八
Shure: Three, two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight
Shure: 四二三四跑二三起
Shure: Four, two, three, four, run, two, three, jump
Shure: 一二三四张二收
Shure: One, two, three, four, stretch, two, collect
Shure: 二三二三四把来二三滑
Shure: Two, three, two, three, four, come, two, three, slide
Shure: 二二三四五六七八
Shure: Two, two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight
Jake:牛啊
Jake: Awesome
Shure: 伸二比心张
Shure: Stretch, two, heart shape, stretch
Shure: 二三走一二
Shure: Two, three, go, one, two
Shure: 二三四五六七八
Shure: Two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight
Shure: 一二三四五六七八
Shure: One, two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight
Shure: 踏步二一二三四
Shure: Step, two, one, two, three, four
Shure: 一二三四跑
Shure: One, two, three, four, run
Shure: 跳二三四
Shure: Jump, two, three, four
Shure: 张二收二三四划二三四
Shure: Stretch, two, collect, two, three, four, slide, two, three, four
Shure: 摸手二三四顶二三四
Shure: Touch hand, two, three, four, push, two, three, four
Shure: 二三四一二三停
Shure: Two, three, four, one, two, three, stop
Lucia: 又卡帧了
Lucia: It lagged again
Shure: 简单
Shure: Simple
Katrina: 第二部分要不要再过一遍
Katrina: Should we go over the second part again?
Shure: 来第二部分
Shure: Let's do the second part
Shure: 再跟他过一遍
Shure: Go over it again
Katrina: 真的吗
Katrina: Really?
Katrina: 哇你就这么自信的吗
Katrina: Wow, you're that confident?
Jake:这是OK
Jake: This is okay
Lucia: 这三部分加起来
Lucia: Adding these three parts together
Lucia: 好像没有到完整的时长
Lucia: It doesn't seem to be the full length
Lucia: 那就从头单曲循环
Lucia: So let's loop it from the beginning
Shure: 一二三四二二三四一二甩
Shure: One, two, three, four, two, two, three, four, one, two, swing
Shure: 二张二开二一二三四
Shure: Two, stretch, two, open, two, one, two, three, four
Lucia: 等一下太快了
Lucia: Wait, too fast
Shure: 41234223412
Shure: Four, one, two, three, four, two, two, three, four, one, two
Shure: 最够一二三四五六七八
Shure: One, two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight.
Shure: 二二三四五六七八
Shure: Two, two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight.
Shure: 转胯三四五六拍拍
Shure: Rotate the hips, three, four, five, six, clap, clap.
Shure: 一二三四五六七停
Shure: One, two, three, four, five, six, seven, stop.
Lucia: 我觉得第二趴还是练一下吧
Lucia: I think we should practice the second part again.
Shure: sorry sorry
Shure: Sorry, sorry.
Lucia: 因为手和脚上动作要合一下
Lucia: Because we need to coordinate the hand and foot movements.
Katrina: 对
Katrina: Yes.
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Yeah.
Katrina: 哈
Katrina: Ha.
Jake:好好下一个环节
Jake: Okay, okay, next segment.
Katrina: 下一个环节
Katrina: Next segment.
Jake:记得花
Jake: Remember the flower.
Katrina: 哦哦哦你说行行
Katrina: Oh, oh, oh, you mean, okay, okay.
Jake:行吧好好好行
Jake: Alright, okay, okay, sure.
Shure: 呀呀呀呀呀呀呀
Shure: Ya ya ya ya ya ya ya.
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahahaha.
Jake:都录着了
Jake: It's all recorded.
Jake:啊哈哈好
Jake: Ahaha, okay.
Katrina: 行吧去选花吧
Katrina: Alright, let's go choose the flowers.
Shure: 他的出镜率不比他来的出镜率低是吧
Shure: His screen time isn't less than when he came, right?
Jake:对我们第第7位选手
Jake: Yeah, our 7th contestant.
Katrina: 几点钟了
Katrina: What time is it?
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Katrina: 哦 4点了
Katrina: Oh, it's 4 o'clock.
Katrina: 是不是也得准备菜啥的啊
Katrina: Should we also start preparing the dishes or something?
Jake:对是的
Jake: Yes, we should.
Katrina: 那就选一下花
Katrina: Then let's choose the flowers.
Jake:对拧个花就是我们的活动
Jake: Yes, picking flowers is our activity.
Jake:我们可以再给你跟跟剧组讲解一下的
Jake: We can also explain it to the crew.
Jake:一些
Jake: A bit.
Jake:也不是就是可能是7天
Jake: It's not, maybe it's 7 days.
Alice:哈哈
Jake:呃看着一一束花就长开
Jake: Look at a bunch of flowers and they will bloom.
Tasha: 没学会
Tasha: Didn't learn it.
Alice:我也不会
Alice:就是那个，哈哈
Jake:走吧下去吧
Jake: Let's go, let's head down.
Alice:走吧
Alice:还有手机
Lucia: 没事
Lucia: It's okay.
Jake:得一直处于摄像头上
Jake: We need to stay in front of the camera.
Jake:那不行没有的话
Jake: It won't work if not.
Lucia: 但是理论上说
Lucia: But theoretically speaking
Lucia: 最后跳怎样其实不是特别重要
Lucia: How we jump in the end isn't really that important
Lucia: 对吧我们只要有这个数据
Lucia: Right, as long as we have the data
Katrina: 写一下名字簿
Katrina: Write the name in the book
Katrina: 然后贴挑一束花
Katrina: Then pick a bouquet of flowers
Katrina: 然后每天要给他拍照
Katrina: And take pictures every day
Katrina: 对因为有了花苞
Katrina: Yes, because there are buds
Katrina: 这就是他会慢慢盛开
Katrina: They will slowly bloom
Katrina: 写名字写名字贴
Katrina: Write the name, stick it on
Shure: 写名字
Shure: Write the name
Jake:写名字写呗
Jake: Write the name, go ahead
Katrina: 那这我挑了
Katrina: Okay, I've chosen this one
Shure: 谁让你挑的呵呵呵
Shure: Who told you to pick it, hahaha
Katrina: 偷偷挑的
Katrina: I secretly picked it
Katrina: 挑是最好的
Katrina: It's the best choice
Katrina: 今晚上还可以再练
Katrina: We can practice again tonight
Jake:哎你你俩有
Jake: Hey, you two have
Jake:有你俩事
Jake: Got something going on
Jake:你俩在打
Jake: You two are fighting
Jake:我出去来
Jake: I'll head out
Katrina: 我的草莓种
Katrina: My strawberry plants
Tasha: 嗯哦
Tasha: Hmm oh
Tasha: 这有人了
Tasha: Someone's here
Tasha: 名花有主了
Tasha: The flower is taken
Tasha: 那就你吧
Tasha: Then it's you
Katrina: 这是要泡几分钟
Katrina: How many minutes should this soak?
Alice:这个好像没有勺药
Alice: It seems like it doesn't have peony
Alice:哦，有一个
Lucia: 有他应该是还没开
Lucia: It should have, it just hasn't opened yet
Lucia: 就是应该各种就里面都都放了
Lucia: Everything should be inside
Alice:应该只有一个
Alice: There should be only one
Katrina: 都都放了芍药的球球
Katrina: Everything has peony bulbs
Katrina: 等它慢慢开就行
Katrina: Just wait for them to open
Alice:芍药只有一个
Katrina: 对这些都是芍药球
Katrina: Yes, these are all peony bulbs
Alice:找个多一点的
Alice: Find one with more
Katrina: 芍药开出
Katrina: Peonies will bloom
Lucia: 啊我可以写了哎
Lucia: Ah, I can write now
Katrina: 来好大呀
Katrina: It's so big
Lucia: 笔上哪去了在这
Lucia: Where did the pen go? Oh, here it is
Katrina: 出来出来出来
Katrina: Come out, come out, come out
Katrina: 自己房间装饰
Katrina: Decorate your own room
Lucia: 可以把它融入到我们的房间装饰里
Lucia: We can incorporate it into our room decor.
Katrina: 你也可以把它放在这客厅某一个位置
Katrina: You can also place it somewhere in the living room.
Katrina: 都行反正你自己管着
Katrina: It’s up to you anyway.
Katrina: 他每天要拍照
Katrina: He needs to take photos every day.
Katrina: 哎呀老学我的口音干什么
Katrina: Oh my, why are you imitating my accent?
Katrina: 哈哈哈可以放外面播
Katrina: Haha, you can place it outside.
Katrina: 他需要那个光合作用吗
Katrina: Does it need photosynthesis?
Shure: 外面不好吧
Shure: Outside isn't good, right?
Katrina: 就是生物钟
Katrina: It's about the biological clock.
Katrina: 他们是需要进行光合作用好像
Katrina: They need photosynthesis, I think.
Katrina: 但是也不能长时间进行光合作用
Katrina: But they can’t do photosynthesis for too long.
Katrina: 你还记得吗
Katrina: Do you remember?
Katrina: 好像会那个什么死掉
Katrina: They might die from that.
Katrina: 就是那个气口
Katrina: I mean, the stomata.
Shure: 蒸腾作用过的
Shure: From too much transpiration.
Katrina: 对对真疼
Katrina: Yes, yes, transpiration.
Lucia: 灯也是可以的吗
Lucia: Can it be a lamp too?
Shure: 你看看这脑子
Shure: Look at this brain.
Katrina: 就是有文化
Katrina: So knowledgeable.
Tasha: 嗯这怎么断了一根
Tasha: Hmm, why is this one broken?
Alice:没关系，让它留着吧
Shure: Dyson i need a corporation
Shure: Dyson, I need a corporation.
Jake:哪去了
Jake: Where did it go?
Shure: 这个放哪呢
Shure: Where should I put this?
Shure: 我那面是阴面不宜养花
Shure: My side is shady, not good for growing flowers.
Alice:掉了
Lucia: 我觉得我房间要放阳台上
Lucia: I think my room needs to put it on the balcony.
Lucia: 挺容易掉下来的
Lucia: It's pretty easy to fall off.
Lucia: 因为我那阳台它并不大
Lucia: Because my balcony isn’t that big.
Jake:呃等下找不着了
Jake: Uh, wait, I can't find it.
Jake:敲完了吗大伙
Jake: Is everyone done knocking?
Alice:你贴了吗
Alice: Did you stick it?
Tasha: 最里面那个
Tasha: The innermost one.
Alice:这个。
Lucia: 今天的照片我把它放哪拍呢
Lucia: Where should I take today's photo?
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha
Katrina: 看看芍药需要几天才能开花
Katrina: Let’s see how long it takes for the peony to bloom.
Lucia: 这里
Lucia: Here.
Jake:幸亏他妈的奶可乐
Jake: Luckily, damn it, milk cola.
Alice:让我给他修剪一下下吧
Alice: Let me trim it a bit.
Jake:挑好了吗
Jake: Did you pick it?
Alice:这个是可以剪花的
Alice: This one can be used for cutting flowers.
Jake:给我留的哪个呀
Jake: Which one did you leave for me?
Tasha: 那要不拿昨天那个剪
Tasha: How about we use the one from yesterday?
Katrina: 是不是最里面那个这个这
Katrina: Is it the innermost one, this one?
Alice:昨天那个在哪
Alice: Where is the one from yesterday?
Jake:这个
Jake: This one.
Jake:这什么花呀
Jake: What kind of flower is this?
Katrina: 这是芍药
Katrina: This is a peony.
Katrina: 这应该也是芍药
Katrina: This should also be a peony.
Katrina: 这是康乃馨
Katrina: This is a carnation.
Katrina: 然后这是百合
Katrina: And this is a lily.
Alice:哎剪子在哪里
Alice: Hey, where are the scissors?
Katrina: 就买了这几种
Katrina: We only bought these kinds.
Tasha: 在这呢
Tasha: Here they are.
Alice:剪花的那个
Alice: The ones for cutting flowers.
Shure: 我给自己的花起个名吧
Shure: I'll give my flower a name.
Katrina: sunshine好土
Katrina: "Sunshine" sounds so cheesy.
Katrina: 你可以叫sunshine或者叫smile
Katrina: You can call it "Sunshine" or "Smile".
Shure: smart可还行
Shure: How about "Smart"?
Katrina: 微笑
Katrina: Smile.
Jake:血汗工厂开店
Jake: Sweatshop is opening a store.
Jake:你你们进去吧
Jake: You guys go in.
Jake:这这两个给你们
Jake: These two are for you.
Katrina: 哇好像那是自习室啊
Katrina: Wow, it looks like a study room.
Jake:这
Jake: This.
Katrina: 就是那补习班
Katrina: It’s like a cram school.
Katrina: 然后现在推门进去减负
Katrina: And now we push the door to reduce the burden.
Lucia: 哈哈对
Lucia: Haha, right.
Katrina: 不准办补习班
Katrina: No cram schools allowed.
Lucia: 不可翻译
Lucia: Cannot translate.
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈哈太搞笑了
Katrina: Hahaha, this is too funny.
Lucia: 不准翻弓
Lucia: No bowing allowed.
Jake:这边贴一个禁止办公
Jake: Let's put a "no working" sign here.
Lucia: 这标这标语我喜欢
Lucia: I like this slogan.
Katrina: 拍拍坐像那种
Katrina: Take a picture like that.
Shure: 你们你们仨是网吧
Shure: Are you guys like an internet cafe?
Shure: 3连坐是吗
Shure: Three seats in a row?
Katrina: 哈哈哈真的像
Katrina: Hahaha, it really looks like one.
Alice:哈哈
Alice: Haha.
Lucia: 这外面这桌子是不是有点有点歪
Lucia: Is this table outside a bit crooked?
Lucia: 这个板
Lucia: This board.
Lucia: 不是就是这板好像不太平
Lucia: No, it's just that this board seems a bit uneven.
Jake:对对对是的是的
Jake: Yeah, yeah, yeah, exactly.
Lucia: 对对对是平时不够哦OK
Lucia: Yeah, yeah, yeah, usually it's not enough. OK.
Jake:他就是不够
Jake: It's just not enough.
Jake:哈哈哈很勉强
Jake: Haha, it's a bit forced.
Jake:不过也行这样就好
Jake: But it's okay, this will do.
Shure: 你们仨准备打点什么
Shure: What are you three planning to play?
Shure: 英雄联盟吗
Shure: League of Legends?
Jake:三个人能打什么呀
Jake: What can three people play?
Jake:帮我拿一下
Jake: Help me grab this.
Shure: 啊
Shure: Huh?
Alice:斗地主
Alice: Landlord.
Jake:帮我拿一下
Jake: Help me grab this.
Shure: 三个人APEX
Shure: Three people can play APEX.
Lucia: 三个人可以
Lucia: Three people can.
Lucia: 三个人可以联机玩刺客信条黑棋
Lucia: Three people can play Assassin's Creed Black Flag online.
Shure: 可以永结无间
Shure: You can play Naraka: Bladepoint.
Jake:好好好行了行了
Jake: Okay, okay, that's enough.
Shure: 这时候赶紧给我们的网易打个广告
Shure: This is the perfect time to advertise for NetEase.
Jake:挺好挺好
Jake: Very good.
Jake:这样好
Jake: This is good.
Shure: 这是干嘛的呀
Shure: What's this for?
Lucia: 做引体向上的哈哈哈
Lucia: To do pull-ups, haha.
Katrina: 做引体销售
Katrina: To do pull-up sales.
Jake:哎
Jake: Hey.
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Shure: 挂个杆然后做引体向上是吗
Shure: Hang a bar and then do pull-ups, right?
Lucia: 对对对
Lucia: Yeah, yeah.
Jake:行行行挺好挺好
Jake: Okay, okay, very good.
Shure: 能能成功吗
Shure: Will it work?
Jake:挺好挺好挺好挺好
Jake: Very good, very good, very good.
Lucia: 我们乱说的
Lucia: We're just making stuff up.
Lucia: 小心一点
Lucia: Be careful.
Shure: 主要我撑不起来
Shure: Mainly, I can't lift myself up.
Shure: 需要给他修剪吗
Shure: Do you need to trim it?
Katrina: 随便你你的话
Katrina: Up to you.
Lucia: 你想修的话可以修呀
Lucia: If you want to trim it, you can.
Jake:也不用那么高
Jake: It doesn't need to be that high.
Shure: 我不修因为我姓荀
Shure: I won't trim it because my last name is Xun.
Jake:就你就卡到这就行
Jake: Just leave it here.
Lucia: 哦哦
Lucia: Oh, okay.
Alice:你不缺修
Alice: No need to fix it.
Jake:高了我怕他摔
Jake: If it's too high, I'm afraid he might fall.
Jake:你看这个就是我的床的入口
Jake: Look, this is the entrance to my bed.
Lucia: 为什么这几个球球到现在还没有开
Lucia: Why haven't these balls opened yet?
Jake:全自动全自动入口你说
Jake: It's a fully automatic entrance, you know.
Shure: 我靠
Shure: Oh my god!
Shure: 你能过来吗
Shure: Can you come over?
Jake:哈哈哈能啊这个一跳我就上上床
Jake: Hahaha, of course, I can jump right onto the bed.
Shure: 这么大地
Shure: It's so big.
Jake:对上床入口
Jake: Yeah, the entrance to the bed.
Shure: 我靠哎呦喂、
Shure: Oh my, wow!
Lucia: sorry一跳就上涨了可爱笑
Lucia: Sorry, just one jump and you're on the bed, so cute.
Jake:对哈哈对对对入口
Jake: Yeah, haha, exactly, the entrance.
Katrina: 嗯理想中的房间
Katrina: Hmm, the ideal room.
Katrina: 哈哈哈学习完倒头就睡
Katrina: Hahaha, just sleep right after studying.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha.
Shure: 真的吗
Shure: Really?
Jake:饶了我吧哈哈哈
Jake: Oh please, spare me, hahaha.
Lucia: 这
Lucia: This...
Lucia: 这个确实是软件工程李小忠的房间了
Lucia: This really is Software Engineer Xiao Zhong's room.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Katrina: 对写完代码直接倒头就睡
Katrina: Yeah, just sleep right after coding.
Jake:哎盘呢
Jake: Hey, where's the disk?
Lucia: 啊哪哪个
Lucia: Ah, which one?
Jake:哦哦哦对对对刚刚对刚刚
Jake: Oh, oh, oh, right, the one from just now.
Lucia: 刚拿过来的这个吗
Lucia: The one you just brought over?
Katrina: 哎二楼这投影仪也可以
Katrina: Hey, this projector on the second floor is pretty good.
Katrina: 那款放点music可以吗
Katrina: Can we play some music with it?
Jake:对易老也是
Jake: Yeah, Old Yi too.
Shure: 来电music
Shure: Play some music.
Katrina: yes反正戴了眼镜了
Katrina: Yes, anyway, I'm wearing glasses.
Jake:来点music
Jake: Play some music.
Katrina: 已经录下来
Katrina: It's already recording.
Jake:你们你们要现在是要干啥呀按照
Jake: What are you guys planning to do now?
Katrina: 我们可以讨论一下
Katrina: We can discuss.
Katrina: 我们的那个房间装饰
Katrina: Our room decoration.
Katrina: 你不说要录录录下来吗
Katrina: Didn't you say you wanted to record it?
Jake:对对然后这个他们应该
Jake: Yeah, yeah, and then they should.
Jake:他说是4五点会有人过来收拾
Jake: He said someone will come to clean around 4 or 5.
Jake:对然后那会收拾
Jake: Yeah, and then they'll clean.
Jake:收拾完我们就扫房间
Jake: After we finish cleaning up, we'll sweep the room.
Jake:就是扫3D扫
Jake: Like a 3D sweep.
Jake:嗯对我靠
Jake: Yeah, oh my god.
Jake:4399 呵呵呵
Jake: 4399, haha.
Katrina: 那几点准备食材呢
Katrina: What time do we start preparing the ingredients?
Jake:呃对那要不现在就开始准备食材吧
Jake: Uh, yeah, how about we start preparing the ingredients now?
Shure: 死神vs火影
Shure: Death vs. Naruto.
Shure: 这不得来一把
Shure: We gotta play a round.
Jake:然后
Jake: Then...
Jake:对现在开始准备食材
Jake: Yes, let's start preparing the ingredients now.
Jake:就现在就看一看
Jake: Let's just take a look now.
Jake:准备准备
Jake: Prepare, prepare.
Katrina: 现在也可以看那个房间装饰购买
Katrina: We can also look at purchasing room decorations now.
Jake:也可以
Jake: That's fine too.
Katrina: 然后5点他来收拾然后扫房间
Katrina: And then at 5, he'll come to clean and sweep the room.
Katrina: 我们只需要稍微
Katrina: We just need to slightly...
Tasha: 把我的也修一下吧
Tasha: Also fix mine, please.
Katrina: 收拾一下我们就下来忙这个呗
Katrina: Clean up a bit, and then we'll come down to handle this.
Alice:好
Katrina: 对扫房间
Katrina: Yes, sweep the room.
Katrina: 扫房间是你们三个弄是吧
Katrina: Sweeping the room is up to you three, right?
Jake:呃这打扫房间是不是
Jake: Uh, is it about cleaning the room?
Tasha: 垃圾全部都放到我的行李箱
Tasha: Put all the trash in my suitcase.
Jake:嗯不用不用
Jake: No, no need for that.
Jake:我们都不用弄
Jake: We don't need to do that.
Alice:我是不是也得收起来
Katrina: OK那我们那个吧
Katrina: OK, then let's...
Tasha: 是那你先放也行
Tasha: It's fine if you put it there for now.
Katrina: 我看我要买什么
Katrina: I'll see what I want to buy.
Jake:OK来关掉4399
Jake: OK, let's turn off 4399.
Katrina: 我想买那我想搞成那种森林主题
Katrina: I want to buy something to make it a forest theme.
Jake:然后那个上上卡
Jake: And then swipe the card.
Lucia: 我我没想好我要怎么样
Lucia: I haven't decided what I want yet.
Katrina: 搞全绿色
Katrina: Make it all green.
Lucia: 我想我想借一个同学的作业抄一下
Lucia: I want to borrow a classmate's homework to copy.
Katrina: 还有
Katrina: Also...
Alice:我本来想弄蓝的
Alice: I originally wanted to make it blue.
Alice:后来发现蓝的太难买
Alice: But then I realized blue is hard to find.
Alice:然后昨天晚上也挑了绿的
Alice: So I picked green last night.
Katrina: 也可以搞那种极简的
Katrina: We can also go for a minimalist style.
Jake:为什么是这个
Jake: Why this one?
Katrina: 就那种无印良品风也行吧
Katrina: Like the MUJI style, that works too.
Alice:对，都可以
Tasha: 这衣服该放在哪里呢
Tasha: Where should we put these clothes?
Alice:我先找一堆绿的我喜欢
Alice: I'll find a bunch of green ones first. I like them.
Katrina: 你房间有那个钩子吗
Katrina: Do you have those hooks in your room?
Alice:青一点的绿
Alice: The greener ones.
Alice:没有
Katrina: 就是我房间有两个钩子
Katrina: I have two hooks in my room.
Katrina: 我感觉可以买那种挂画海报呢
Katrina: I think we can buy those poster hangers.
Katrina: 因为他不给贴
Katrina: Because they don't let us stick things.
Shure: 这样吧我们建一个歌单
Shure: How about this, let's create a playlist.
Shure: 然后大家一人报一个歌名好吧
Shure: And then everyone can suggest a song, okay?
Katrina: 就是就是
Katrina: Yes, yes.
Katrina: 大家可以想听什么自己输进去
Katrina: Everyone can put in whatever they want to listen to.
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay.
Katrina: 然后我们搞随机播放
Katrina: And then we'll do a random shuffle.
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay.
Katrina: 哇有点像那个随机舞蹈了哈哈
Katrina: Wow, it's kinda like a random dance, haha.
Shure: 来大家先一人说一个歌名
Shure: Alright, everyone suggest a song first.
Shure: 我先都不放
Shure: I won't play anything yet.
Shure: 然后都加到歌单里
Shure: Then we'll add them to the playlist.
Shure: 然后这个歌单随便放可以吧
Shure: And then we can shuffle the playlist, okay?
Katrina: 上想听的歌
Katrina: Put in the songs you want to hear.
Lucia: 我打开我的apple music
Lucia: I'll open my Apple Music.
Katrina: 好有意思啊
Katrina: So interesting.
Lucia: 然后突然发现
Lucia: And then I suddenly realized...
Lucia: 我的我的APP账号没登在里面
Lucia: My app account isn't logged in.
Jake:我操没关系没关系没关系没关系
Jake: Damn, it's okay, it's okay, it's okay, it's okay.
Lucia: 所以找不到自己签的歌单了
Lucia: So I can't find my playlist.
Katrina: 好有好有意思
Katrina: It's really interesting.
Lucia: 我得重新登录一下
Lucia: I need to log in again.
Jake:我我我觉
Jake: I, I, I think...
Shure: 你要什么
Shure: What do you need?
Tasha: 就这样
Tasha: Just like this.
Katrina: 来一首那个陶喆的爱很简单
Katrina: Let's play David Tao's "Love is Simple."
Jake:11号
Jake: Number 11.
Shure: 爱很简单真的吗
Shure: "Love is Simple," really?
Jake:看一看你看一看
Jake: Take a look, see for yourself.
Jake:看看这里面是什么
Jake: Check out what's inside here.
Katrina: 哇这首歌每次都是演唱会的压轴
Katrina: Wow, this song is always the finale at concerts.
Jake:他难道会这有人换吗
Jake: Will there be anyone to change it?
Shure: 陶喆
Shure: David Tao.
Jake:1号没人
Jake: Number 1, no one.
Shure: 哦好像
Shure: Oh, seems like...
Jake:换换下来就是这个
Jake: Switching it would be this one.
Jake:看看有没有
Jake: Let's see if we have...
Shure: 不是没有陶喆版本
Shure: No, there's no David Tao version.
Jake:东西万一要是原来送一个256
Jake: What if the stuff originally came with a 256GB?
Katrina: 啊你没有VIP是吗
Katrina: Ah, you don't have VIP, do you?
Shure: 啊这个带的都好
Shure: Ah, this one is good.
Shure: 好先不慌
Shure: Okay, no rush.
Shure: 先加入歌单
Shure: Add it to the playlist first.
Shure: 收藏一个
Shure: Add it to favorites.
Katrina: 等会等会
Katrina: Wait, wait.
Katrina: 这样拍张照好好
Katrina: Let's take a picture like this.
Katrina: 有那种综艺的感觉
Katrina: It has that variety show vibe.
Shure: 是的还有什么
Shure: Yes, what else?
Lucia: 我我我点那个打雷姐的video games
Lucia: I, I, I want to play Lana Del Rey's "Video Games."
Shure: VEDD啊VIDD UVM
Shure: VEDD, uh, VIDD UVM
Shure: 这个是什么
Shure: What's this?
Jake:哎可以
Jake: Oh, that's good.
Lucia: 拉娜德雷的对
Lucia: Lana Del Rey's, yes.
Jake:这电脑有吗
Jake: Does this computer have it?
Choiszt: 应该每个电脑都一样
Choiszt: Should be the same on every computer.
Jake:右边没有吗
Jake: Not on the right?
Katrina: 还有人吗
Katrina: Anyone else?
Shure: 还有什么
Shure: What else?
Lucia: 然后还有什么
Lucia: And what else?
Jake:不是不是他
Jake: No, no, not him.
Alice:蝴蝶
Alice: Butterfly.
Jake:你左边没有吗
Jake: Nothing on your left?
Shure: 蝴蝶谁的
Shure: Whose "Butterfly"?
Katrina: 谁的蝴蝶
Katrina: Whose "Butterfly"?
Alice:淘集集
Alice: TaoJiji.
Jake:我靠你他妈同款电脑我都学不会
Jake: Damn it, I can't even learn it on the same model computer.
Katrina: 你也喜欢这首歌吗
Katrina: Do you like this song too?
Jake:哈哈哈你搞笑了
Jake: Hahaha, you're funny.
Alice:我挺喜欢的
Alice: I quite like it.
Katrina: 这是我超喜欢的一首歌
Katrina: It's one of my favorite songs.
Jake:我靠哈哈哈哈哈耶
Jake: Damn it, hahaha, yeah.
Katrina: 我当时当时分手的时候狂听这首歌
Katrina: I listened to it a lot when I broke up back then.
Shure: 还有什么
Shure: What else?
Jake:我毫无encounter呢
Jake: I have no encounter.
Lucia: 诶薇薇呢
Lucia: Hey, where's Tasha?
Jake:我靠
Jake: Oh crap
Alice:上去收拾东西喽
Alice: She went upstairs to pack her stuff
Lucia: 啊她还没有报报歌
Lucia: Ah, she hasn't picked a song yet
Katrina: 当这世界已经准备着
Katrina: When the world is ready
Katrina: 我可以多多搞一场
Katrina: I can do another show
Shure: 我的宝贝宝贝
Shure: My baby, baby
Jake:好这样这个这个是1111是空的
Jake: Okay, so this one, this one is empty
Tasha: 嗯拍照去了
Tasha: Yeah, she's taking pictures
Lucia: 那我点那个滚石的
Lucia: Then I'll pick a Rolling Stones song
Alice:嗯还可以吗
Alice: Hmm, is that okay?
Lucia: 不是滚石枪花的希文沃
Lucia: Not Rolling Stones, Guns N' Roses' "November Rain"
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Yeah
Lucia: 哈哈超喜欢这个
Lucia: Haha, I love this one so much
Shure: 哎呦
Shure: Oh wow
Jake:还没有一张还没有
Jake: Not a single one yet, not yet
Lucia: 突然想起来
Lucia: Suddenly remembered
Jake:行这样吧
Jake: Alright, let's do it this way
Jake:就是你这二楼的
Jake: So, you're on the second floor
Shure: 这才是老摇滚
Shure: This is real rock
Jake:呃视频主搞一楼的好吧
Jake: The main video is on the first floor, okay?
Katrina: 经常在听
Katrina: I listen to it a lot
Lucia: 经常在听老歌
Lucia: I often listen to old songs
Jake:你你不用
Jake: You don't need to
Jake:就是首先你下一个下一个
Jake: So first, you, next, you
Jake:VLC VLC VLC VLC啊
Jake: VLC VLC VLC VLC, yeah
Shure: 谁刚刚没有点歌来着要点歌
Shure: Who just didn't pick a song? Wanna pick one?
Lucia: 微微点歌吗
Lucia: Tasha, did you pick a song?
Katrina: 他点了蝴蝶
Katrina: She picked "Butterfly"
Tasha: 我吗
Tasha: Me?
Katrina: 哦那个我也点过
Katrina: Oh, I picked that one too
Shure: 蝴蝶点过了
Shure: "Butterfly" has been picked
Lucia: 嗯对
Lucia: Yeah, right
Lucia: 你还你还你
Lucia: You still, you still
Lucia: 还没点应该
Lucia: Haven't picked one, right?
Shure: 还有谁没点
Shure: Who else hasn't picked?
Tasha: 路亚要点一首是吗
Tasha: Does Luya want to pick one?
Lucia: 对也可以多点
Lucia: Yeah, she can pick more
Katrina: 对对对
Katrina: Yeah, yeah, yeah
Jake:这边要点陈奕迅
Jake: Let's pick an Eason Chan song
Lucia: 两首可以点哪个浮夸
Lucia: Can we select two songs, which one is "Exaggeration"?
Katrina: 来首陈奕迅的
Katrina: Let's play a song by Eason Chan.
Tasha: 我手机呢
Tasha: Where's my phone?
Shure: 周杰伦没有我是
Shure: There's no Jay Chou for me.
Katrina: 我想听那个爱是一本书
Katrina: I want to listen to "Love is a Book".
Katrina: 就是陈奕迅的爱是一本书
Katrina: It's Eason Chan's "Love is a Book".
Shure: 是一本书OK
Shure: "Love is a Book", okay.
Jake:哎你这怎么
Jake: Hey, what's up?
Jake:你看咋的
Jake: Look, what's going on?
Lucia: 我也来帮陈奕迅点一个
Lucia: I'll also request an Eason Chan song.
Jake:哎呦哎呦卧槽
Jake: Oh, oh my gosh.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Jake:卧槽你你是几天没睡觉的
Jake: Damn, how many days haven't you slept?
Shure: OK先
Shure: Okay, first...
Jake:呃你你等啊
Jake: Uh, wait a second...
Jake:你你拧一下
Jake: You, you twist it.
Jake:哈哈哈啊
Jake: Haha.
Jake:拧一下你拧一下
Jake: Twist it, twist it.
Jake:好你你是谁
Jake: Okay, who are you?
Jake:你要干嘛
Jake: What do you want to do?
Jake:OK你现在电脑里面
Jake: Okay, now, on your computer...
Jake:你你现在电脑里面是什么旗号
Jake: What's the flag on your computer now?
Jake:旗号拔出来先
Jake: Pull out the flag first.
Jake:不要旗号
Jake: No flag.
Katrina: 确实我觉得网易云唯一不足
Katrina: Yeah, I think the only flaw with NetEase Cloud is...
Katrina: 就是没有周杰伦
Katrina: It doesn't have Jay Chou.
Katrina: 就是你得切另一个软件
Katrina: You have to switch to another app.
Lucia: 啊是
Lucia: Yeah.
Lucia: 网易云上压根就没啊OK
Lucia: NetEase Cloud doesn't have it at all, okay.
Shure: 没有那个版权
Shure: No license for that.
Shure: 来吧随机播放
Shure: Come on, shuffle play.
Shure: Steam首先放哪个
Shure: Which one to play first on Steam?
Jake:这个其实咱装可以
Jake: Actually, this one can be installed.
Jake:没问题没问题没问题
Jake: No problem, no problem, no problem.
Shure: 就先放你这个吧好吧
Shure: Let's play yours first, okay?
Katrina: 然后你按随机看你这音效效果怎么样
Katrina: Then you hit shuffle and see how the sound effects are.
Jake:7号
Jake: Number 7.
Jake:哎
Jake: Hey.
Jake:对然后呃西明珠从1号开始稍微容
Jake: Yeah, then, uh, West Pearl starts from number 1 slightly...
Lucia: 谁的有谁的电话吗这是
Lucia: Whose phone is this?
Jake:易一点对你你稍微难一点
Jake: It's a bit easier for you, just a bit harder.
Tasha: 啊我手机居然在这里
Tasha: Ah, my phone's actually here.
Katrina: 贴的啥安康
Katrina: What did you stick on there, Ankang?
Jake:哈哈哈你从你从9号开始
Jake: Hahaha, you start from the 9th.
Shure: 这是我原来乐队的名字
Shure: That's my old band's name.
Jake:8号在一楼
Jake: The 8th is on the first floor.
Jake:呃9号
Jake: Uh, the 9th.
Jake:对十一号跳过去
Jake: Yes, then jump to the 11th.
Jake:对对
Jake: Yes, yes.
Jake:然后你们要做的事情是把每一层
Jake: Then what you need to do is for each floor...
Jake:就是按楼层
Jake: by floor...
Jake:这个是一楼
Jake: This is the first floor.
Katrina: 哇对味
Katrina: Wow, perfect match.
Jake:哎这是一楼
Jake: Hey, this is the first floor.
Jake:这是二楼
Jake: This is the second floor.
Katrina: 爽啦
Katrina: Awesome.
Jake:然后我标一下
Jake: Then I'll mark it.
Jake:给我一个那个纸
Jake: Give me that paper.
Jake:还能是谁哈哈
Jake: Who else could it be, haha.
Jake:对啊郝哲
Jake: Yeah, Haozhe.
Katrina: 哎呀怎么把我网名念出来了
Katrina: Oh no, why did you say my screen name out loud?
Jake:呵为什么还在3月2号
Jake: Haha, why is it still on March 2nd?
Lucia: 太激动了不想改
Lucia: Too excited to change it.
Jake:等到明年3月2号是吧
Jake: Wait until next March 2nd, right?
Katrina: 等到什么时候再看下一场了再改
Katrina: Wait until the next event to change it.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Katrina: 对我看第一场
Katrina: Yeah, I'll watch the first show.
Katrina: 在武汉我抢到了前驱票
Katrina: In Wuhan, I got the early bird tickets.
Katrina: 3月2号 哦
Katrina: March 2nd, oh.
Katrina: 那时候刚来学校一会
Katrina: Just started school back then.
Lucia: sorry哈哈哈
Lucia: Sorry, hahaha.
Katrina: 但是但是
Katrina: But, but...
Katrina: 他现在嗓子已经回春很多了
Katrina: His voice has improved a lot now.
Katrina: 他把那心乱肺的高音给飙上去
Katrina: He can hit those high notes effortlessly.
Jake:那就整整火锅呗
Jake: Then let's have hotpot.
Jake:然后聊一聊你们
Jake: And chat about you guys.
Katrina: 我要买一下我的东西
Katrina: I need to buy my stuff.
Jake:好让数据丰富起来
Jake: Okay, let's get more data.
Katrina: 今天可丰富了
Katrina: It's really rich today.
Katrina: 今天还那么多肢体动作
Katrina: So many gestures today too.
Jake:确实对现在也要丰富起来
Jake: Yeah, we need to enrich it now.
Lucia: 对对
Lucia: Yes, yes.
Alice:给你剪
Alice: I'll cut it for you.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Mhm.
Katrina: 哎我靠真好看
Katrina: Oh wow, this looks so good.
Lucia: 到现在还没想好买啥
Lucia: I still haven't decided what to buy.
Katrina: 其实现在好多那种
Katrina: Actually, there are many
Katrina: 就是那种很有意思的做的家居品牌
Katrina: interesting home decor brands now.
Lucia: 我选一个整屋定制哈哈哈
Lucia: I'll choose a customized whole house, haha.
Katrina: 整屋定制
Katrina: Customized whole house.
Katrina: 好好看哈哈
Katrina: Looks so good, haha.
Katrina: 整屋定制
Katrina: Customized whole house.
Katrina: 你让杨老板给你报销
Katrina: You should ask Jake to reimburse you.
Jake:外包是吧
Jake: Outsourcing, right?
Lucia: 对对对哈哈
Lucia: Yeah, yeah, haha.
Jake:外包呵呵
Jake: Outsourcing, hehe.
Katrina: 整屋定制
Katrina: Customized whole house.
Jake:500块钱 200外包
Jake: 500 yuan, 200 for outsourcing.
Jake:呵呵呵
Jake: Hehehe.
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Ha.
Jake:全程外包
Jake: Full outsourcing.
Jake:不是不是VLC啊
Jake: Not VLC, right?
Lucia: 因为这种对于我这个选择恐惧症来说
Lucia: Because for someone like me with decision paralysis,
Lucia: 真的很难搞
Lucia: it's really hard to deal with.
Katrina: 我还有一个小阳台
Katrina: I also have a small balcony.
Katrina: 我阳台上可以放东西
Katrina: I can put things on the balcony.
Jake:你瞎盗版了
Jake: You're pirating it.
Jake:哈哈哈学学
Jake: Haha, learn.
Jake:呃这样你你跟他一样
Jake: Uh, so you do it like him.
Jake:你腰部也低一点
Jake: Lower your waist a bit too.
Tasha: 哈减无可减
Tasha: Haha, can't cut any more.
Jake:然后这个高一点
Jake: Then raise this up a bit.
Jake:我想想怎么办
Jake: Let me think how to do this.
Jake:因为
Jake: Because
Jake:因为你这个硬盘也要放在这个地方
Jake: Because you need to place the hard drive here.
Jake:然后但是这个硬盘你你不能摔着
Jake: But you can't let the hard drive fall.
Jake:你懂吗所以你行行行
Jake: You know? So yeah.
Jake:哈哈哈对然后插上
Jake: Haha, right, then plug it in.
Katrina: 有一种岁月静好的感觉
Katrina: It gives a feeling of peace and tranquility.
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Mhm.
Katrina: 他们在工作
Katrina: They're working.
Lucia: 要不然我搞个照片墙
Lucia: How about I make a photo wall?
Katrina: 然后这边在放歌
Katrina: And then playing music here.
Katrina: 这边在剪花
Katrina: And cutting flowers here.
Shure: 我给你们加油打气
Shure: I'll cheer you guys on.
Shure: 我给你们跳yes okay
Shure: I'll dance "yes okay" for you.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哎
Lucia: Hahaha, hey.
Jake:对唔出
Jake: Can't figure it out.
Lucia: 我觉得他动作已经很得精髓了
Lucia: I think he's really got the essence of it.
Jake:要不把碗洗了哈哈哈
Jake: How about you wash the dishes, haha.
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay.
Jake:先生你好
Jake: Hello, sir.
Jake:卧槽哈哈哈你怎么弄的
Jake: Whoa, hahaha, how did you do that?
Jake:呃OK
Jake: Uh, okay.
Jake:那那你直接这样嘛
Jake: Then, just do it like this.
Jake:你你觉得怎么样
Jake: What do you think?
Jake:贴着贴哎
Jake: Stick it, stick it, hey.
Jake:能能贴吗贴着吧
Jake: Can you stick it? Just stick it.
Jake:不行歇着歇着好
Jake: No, take a break, take a break, okay.
Jake:oh
Jake: Oh.
Jake:拿个工具
Jake: Get a tool.
Jake:哎呦卧槽
Jake: Ouch, whoa.
Jake:呵呵呵挺好
Jake: Hahaha, it's pretty good.
Jake:没事没事
Jake: It's okay, it's okay.
Jake:问题不大
Jake: Not a big deal.
Jake:哦那你看怎么贴
Jake: Oh, then see how you stick it.
Jake:爱爱咋贴咋贴
Jake: However you want to stick it, stick it.
Lucia: 飘窗柜好像很有用的鸭子
Lucia: The bay window cabinet seems really useful.
Jake:你弄矮一点
Jake: Make it shorter.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Jake:那贴一个
Jake: Then stick one.
Jake:等一下贴硬盘上 1 2
Jake: Wait, stick it on the hard drive. One, two.
Katrina: 天呐好多好看的都是要做手工
Katrina: Oh my god, so many beautiful ones need to be handmade.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
Katrina: 啊直接到浮夸了
Katrina: Ah, it's directly exaggerated.
Jake:教外国人用淘宝也挺好
Jake: Teaching foreigners to use Taobao is also good.
Jake:让他们羡慕去
Jake: Let them be envious.
Lucia: 有哪个购物平台给咱给赞助吗
Lucia: Is there any shopping platform sponsoring us?
Lucia: 就多用用他们的
Lucia: Just use theirs more.
Jake:这还有个帽子还戴着呢哈
Jake: There's still a hat here, and I'm wearing it, haha.
Lucia: 啊亚马逊是吗
Lucia: Ah, Amazon, right?
Lucia: 他们已经会用了不用教
Lucia: They already know how to use it, no need to teach them.
Jake:哈
Jake: Ha.
Katrina: 我要买几个摆在我那
Katrina: I want to buy a few to place at my place.
Jake:这就直接导
Jake: Just import it directly.
Jake:自然前面的数据都不太好
Jake: Naturally, the previous data wasn't very good.
Jake:呃这个
Jake: Uh, this...
Jake:你们这个硬盘里面贴这个
Jake: You guys put this on the hard drive.
Jake:暗号是第二层
Jake: The code is on the second layer.
Jake:所以对对对
Jake: So, right, right, right.
Jake:专门专门做Pro的第二层
Jake: It's specifically for the Pro's second layer.
Jake:然后你按照每一个相机
Jake: Then you follow each camera.
Jake:呃然后每一天
Jake: Uh, and then each day.
Jake:他会切自己会切
Jake: It'll cut by itself.
Alice:还满意吗
Alice: Are you satisfied?
Tasha: 可以呀谢谢
Tasha: It's fine, thank you.
Jake:呃我来跟你命名
Jake: Uh, I'll name it for you.
Jake:看好看好
Jake: Watch closely.
Jake:然后这个先上
Jake: And then put this on first.
Jake:先上这个盘对吧
Jake: First, this disk, right?
Jake:这个这个盘
Jake: This, this disk.
Jake:好呃呃
Jake: Okay, uh, uh...
Jake:还没连上
Jake: Haven't connected yet.
Jake:连上
Jake: Connect it.
Jake:这个
Jake: This...
Jake:后边后边
Jake: At the back, at the back.
Jake:插上了这边
Jake: Plug it in here.
Jake:如果我原来帮他插上了
Jake: If I originally plugged it in for him...
Jake:然后你现在没有
Jake: And now you don't have it...
Jake:他要可热化一下
Jake: He needs to hot-swap it.
Shure: 你要洗手是吗
Shure: You want to wash your hands, right?
Jake:你你别搁错
Jake: Don't mix it up.
Shure: 这锅是
Shure: This pot is...
Alice: 用这个刷吧
Alice: Use this brush.
Lucia: 抄作业了
Lucia: Copying homework.
Lucia: 哈哈没事
Lucia: Haha, it's fine.
Tasha: 什么都没干
Tasha: Didn't do anything.
Lucia: 你做作业
Lucia: Do your homework.
Lucia: 你放心的做作业
Lucia: Just focus on your homework.
Jake:好结束了
Jake: Okay, it's over.
Jake:然后放对
Jake: Then put it right.
Lucia: 啊好难过死
Lucia: Ah, this is so frustrating!
Jake:一般放个瓶
Jake: Usually, just put a bottle.
Lucia: 啊你剪的这个好漂亮呀
Lucia: Wow, you cut this so beautifully!
Alice:这两都是我捡的
Lucia: 啊这也好看
Lucia: Ah, this one looks great too.
Lucia: 这面看特别有层次感
Lucia: This side has a lot of depth.
Lucia: 啊你的这个也还没开
Lucia: Ah, yours haven't bloomed yet.
Alice:嗯还没有呢
Alice: Yeah, not yet.
Lucia: 我那个也是
Lucia: Mine too.
Lucia: 都还没开
Lucia: They haven't bloomed yet.
Alice:来欣赏一下
Alice: Let's appreciate it.
Jake:好看
Jake: Looks good.
Jake:是修剪了一遍
Jake: It was pruned once.
Alice:yes
Alice: Yes.
Jake:修剪了狠狠的修剪了一遍
Jake: Pruned, really pruned once.
Alice:也没有狠狠一般般
Alice: Not really, it's still pretty average.
Jake:确实好看了很多
Jake: It does look a lot better.
Lucia: 我好奇一下大家都写的什么符号
Lucia: I'm curious what symbols everyone drew.
Alice:我给他画的翅膀
Alice: I drew wings for him.
Lucia: 小翅膀
Lucia: Little wings.
Alice:但是画的有点丑
Alice: But it's kind of ugly.
Jake:还没写写一下
Jake: Haven't written it down yet.
Alice:我是个星
Alice: I'm a star.
Lucia: 我是个小太阳
Lucia: I'm a little sun.
Lucia: 啊雨轩是直接写的名字
Lucia: Oh, Yuxuan just wrote their name directly.
Katrina: 哦香薰
Katrina: Oh, aromatherapy.
Katrina: 我想买个小香薰
Katrina: I want to buy a little aromatherapy.
Lucia: 买一串星星灯
Lucia: Buy a string of star lights.
Lucia: 直接给房间上挂一圈就完事了
Lucia: Just hang them around the room and you're done.
Jake:哎
Jake: Hey.
Jake:这是我的
Jake: This is mine.
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
Katrina: 火
Katrina: Fire.
Katrina: 哈哈哈受不
Katrina: Hahaha, can't handle it?
Lucia: 他是什么花
Lucia: What kind of flower is he?
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Lucia: 哇很直接了当
Lucia: Wow, very straightforward.
Jake:就是只要NB4 其他的都不用
Jake: As long as it's NB4, you don't need anything else.
Jake:不用啊哎
Jake: No need, hey.
Jake:人呢他会吗
Jake: Can he do it?
Jake:尼玛哈哈哈你咋跑了
Jake: Nima, hahaha, why did you run away?
Jake:我回来了
Jake: I'm back.
Jake:哈哈哈你结束
Jake: Hahaha, you're done.
Jake:尼玛不让你
Jake: Nima, I won't let you.
Jake:哈哈哈 15十五号
Jake: Hahaha, the 15th, fifteenth.
Jake:十六号秒
Jake: Sixteenth second.
Jake:你这是不是
Jake: Is this okay?
Jake:哎其实没毛病
Jake: Actually, it's fine.
Jake:哈哈哈多少慢了点
Jake: Hahaha, just a bit slow.
Jake:只是慢了
Jake: Just a bit slow.
Jake:有读卡器可以买读卡器
Jake: You can buy a card reader.
Shure: 这里有吧这里有
Shure: There's one here, right?
Jake:就一个硬盘啊
Jake: Just one hard drive.
Jake:呃应该就是很讲究的命名方式
Jake: Uh, it should be a very sophisticated naming method.
Shure: 这个面糊会不会堵下水道呢
Shure: Will this batter clog the drain?
Jake:是你呃你现在怎么命名呢
Jake: So how are you naming it now?
Jake:你现在就直接拖进去是吧
Jake: You just drag it in directly, right?
Jake:对对对我操
Jake: Yeah, yeah, yeah, damn.
Jake:你他妈太粗暴了
Jake: You're so rough.
Jake:对对对太太太粗暴了
Jake: Yeah, yeah, too, too, too rough.
Jake:来来来这个法2好吧
Jake: Come, come, this method is better, okay?
Jake:呃那个你是几号相机
Jake: Uh, which camera are you using?
Jake:那你写个一一一新建文件加一
Jake: Then create a new file and add one.
Jake:呃然后进去
Jake: Uh, then go in.
Jake:进去新建一个202404
Jake: Go in and create a new one, 202404.
Jake:你直接建吧
Jake: Just create it.
Jake:然后
Jake: Then
Jake:到时候你看他创建日期是什么时候
Jake: Check the creation date later.
Jake:你就往里面涂
Jake: Just put it in.
Jake:每一个视频
Jake: Every video.
Jake:他有自己的充电日期
Jake: It has its own charging date.
Lucia: 偏强
Lucia: A bit strong.
Jake:快速干嘛啊
Jake: Why so fast?
Jake:啊对这这够快了
Jake: Yeah, this is fast enough.
Jake:比迈克快多了
Jake: Much faster than Mike.
Jake:哎迈克也很快
Jake: Hey, Mike is also fast.
Jake:写个patter
Jake: Write a pattern.
Jake:你可以你可以建很多
Jake: You can, you can create a lot.
Jake:你可以建到22
Jake: You can create up to 22.
Jake:然后这个里面再写相机的那个
Jake: And then write the camera's...
Jake:相机的编号
Jake: The camera's serial number.
Jake:对你编号在啊
Jake: Yeah, the serial number is there.
Jake:哎你是二人吗
Jake: Hey, are you number two?
Jake:22楼吗没有没有没有你
Jake: 22nd floor? No, no, no, you...
Jake:你在我最外层
Jake: You are in my outermost layer.
Jake:就这个你要你要
Jake: So this, you need to...
Jake:拖到一个
Jake: Drag it to one...
Jake:再到20号
Jake: Then to the 20th.
Jake:呃没关系
Jake: Uh, it's okay.
Jake:见到17也行
Jake: Seeing the 17th is fine.
Jake:见到17吧
Jake: See the 17th.
Jake:然后我就把
Jake: Then I will...
Jake:对你看到日期
Jake: Right, you see the date?
Jake:你看日期了吗
Jake: Did you see the date?
Jake:9号相机
Jake: Camera number 9.
Jake:你的一号相机
Jake: Your camera number one.
Jake:他从9号相机开始
Jake: He starts from camera number 9.
Shure: 搞定
Shure: Done.
Shure: 全倍亮跟你讲
Shure: Full brightness, I'm telling you.
Jake:不用不用
Jake: No need, no need.
Jake:对啊我我觉得不应该这么办了
Jake: Yeah, I think it shouldn't be done this way.
Jake:气死我了
Jake: I'm so pissed.
Jake:我原来想一个小时在这转一圈搞定
Jake: I originally thought it would take an hour to finish this.
Jake:他妈头崩了
Jake: Damn, my head's about to explode.
Shure: 啊搞定
Shure: Ah, done.
Jake:是我原来还没有买这种卡
Jake: Yeah, I didn't buy this kind of card before.
Jake:所以说我得插到GoPro
Jake: So I had to plug it into the GoPro.
Jake:就是把那个充电线给插电脑上
Jake: Just plug the charging cable into the computer.
Jake:然后开始倒
Jake: And then start transferring.
Jake:然后每一个一个一个跑
Jake: And then one by one, run.
Jake:就是原来的方案是推着这个小桌子
Jake: The original plan was to push this small table.
Jake:然后推着到处跑
Jake: And then push it around.
Jake:然后碰到傻逼了
Jake: And then encountered an idiot.
Jake:哈哈哈太难了
Jake: Hahaha, it's too difficult.
Shure: 在点什么
Shure: What are you clicking on?
Jake:太慢了又慢又麻烦
Jake: Too slow, both slow and troublesome.
Alice:没事，玩的
Jake:they are就两两个人
Jake: they are just two people.
Jake:好歹一人一层啊
Jake: At least one per layer.
Jake:我他妈一人15个
Jake: I'm doing 15 alone.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Lucia: 我要不要去搬俩凳子下来
Lucia: Should I go get two more chairs?
Shure: 我一会在上面吃还是下面吃火锅
Shure: Am I going to eat hotpot upstairs or downstairs?
Jake:我在下面吃
Jake: I'll eat downstairs.
Lucia: 啊啥
Lucia: What?
Lucia: 我们是在上面还是下面
Lucia: Are we eating upstairs or downstairs?
Katrina: 现在在shoping
Katrina: We're shopping now.
Lucia: 如果在下面的话我就再搬俩凳子下来
Lucia: If we're eating downstairs, I'll go get two more chairs.
Jake:小品
Jake: Little skit.
Katrina: shoping中
Katrina: Still shopping.
Jake:好好在下面吃
Jake: Fine, we'll eat downstairs.
Lucia: 那行
Lucia: Alright.
Jake:呃我想一下在下面吃
Jake:可以在下面去
Jake: We can go downstairs.
Jake:你出来被拍吧
Jake: You come out and get recorded.
Jake:你就给点
Jake: Just give some...
Jake:你给点素材出来拍
Jake: Give some material to record.
Jake:给你你的座位嘛座位
Jake: Here's your seat, your seat.
Shure: 席地而坐
Shure: Sitting on the ground.
Shure: 大象席地而坐
Shure: Like an elephant sitting on the ground.
Jake:一个吉他
Jake: A guitar.
Jake:还是被扫过的
Jake: But it's been scanned.
Jake:这是一个赛博系统
Jake: This is a cyber system.
Shure: 是吗啊
Shure: Really?
Shure: 他有自己的生命了
Shure: It has its own life now.
Jake:对但是他不是赛博的
Jake: Yes, but it's not cyber.
Jake:你是赛博的
Jake: You are cyber.
Shure: 那也就是现在
Shure: So now...
Jake:呵呵哈哈哈哈哈哈啊
Jake: Haha, hahaha.
Shure: 就是凭空就有一个人
Shure: So it's like a person just appeared...
Shure: 有一把吉他在这里自己发声是吗
Shure: And a guitar is making sounds by itself, right?
Jake:谢谢谢谢
Jake: Thanks, thanks.
Lucia: 我们差差31234567然后我们有几个人
Lucia: We are short 3, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, so how many people do we have?
Jake:对
Jake: Right.
Lucia: 八个人再拿一个
Lucia: Eight people, we need one more.
Jake:酒来酒
Jake: Bring the wine, wine.
Jake:I99号卡
Jake: I99 card.
Jake:刚刚是谁拿走的
Jake: Who just took it?
Jake:9号 海
Jake: Number 9, Hai.
Shure: 以点歌然后加入到歌单就好
Shure: Just order the song and add it to the playlist.
Jake:树确实爽多了啊
Jake: The tree is indeed much better now.
Shure: 好好好
Shure: Okay, okay, okay.
Shure: 对加入到歌单
Shure: Yes, add it to the playlist.
Shure: 然后放入到易狗里面
Shure: Then put it into Yigou.
Shure: 就是你说那更多那块
Shure: You mean that more section.
Shure: 然后收藏
Shure: Then save it.
Shure: 然后到一狗里面
Shure: And put it in Yigou.
Shure: 想想我们要干什么家人们
Shure: Think about what we should do, everyone.
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah.
Shure: 你们会翻绳吗会吗
Shure: Do you know how to play with ropes? Do you?
Shure: 拿绳来
Shure: Bring the rope.
Shure: 咱们不至于这么赛博吧
Shure: We shouldn't be this cyber, right?
Shure: 有没有棉线什么的
Shure: Is there any cotton string or something?
Jake:以房间装扮吗
Jake: To decorate the room?
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah.
Jake:房间装扮吗
Jake: Room decoration?
Shure: 我的房间好像没有什么太装扮的东西
Shure: My room doesn't really have much decoration.
Jake:多少啊
Jake: How much?
Tasha: 20
Tasha: 20.
Shure: 这个角落真的好好看
Shure: This corner looks really nice.
Jake:太难了
Jake: It's too hard.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Jake:就是这个
Jake: This is it.
Jake:go Pro晚上到几点
Jake: Go Pro, until what time at night?
Nicous: 晚上给我戴个眼镜
Nicous: Give me glasses at night.
Jake:这个眼睛
Jake: These glasses.
Jake:那你有热吧
Jake: Aren't you hot?
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Shure: 我们昨天看见他的衣服了
Shure: We saw his clothes yesterday.
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah.
Shure: 那我们去扒他衣服去
Shure: Let's go strip his clothes off.
Shure: 扒他裤子
Shure: Strip his pants.
Jake:对已经关了
Jake: Yeah, it's already off.
Jake:没电了应该
Jake: It should be out of battery.
Jake:可能没电了
Jake: It might be out of battery.
Jake:sorry今天还在
Jake: Sorry, it's still on today.
Shure: 应该是没电了
Shure: It should be out of battery.
Jake:插充电宝
Jake: Plug in the power bank.
Shure: 那有一打刚才
Shure: There was a hit just now.
Jake:算再录录了再没人再看一下时间
Jake: Let's record more, and then if no one is here, check the time again.
Jake:救命哈哈
Jake: Help, haha.
Katrina: 你在干什么呀
Jake:计时计时
Jake: Timing, timing.
Jake:对对对然后每人都要看
Jake: Yeah, yeah, everyone needs to see it.
Alice:装饰我的花
Jake:每人都要看
Jake: Everyone needs to see it.
Katrina: 这是什么花
Jake:啊不不不
Jake: Ah, no, no, no.
Jake:一个秒表
Jake: A stopwatch.
Alice:纸
Jake:一个精确到后几位的秒表
Jake: A stopwatch that is precise to the last few digits.
Katrina: 我靠，好厉害
Jake:这个不中
Jake: This won't work.
Jake:是不是今天下午命名
Jake: Are we naming it this afternoon?
Jake:上面规定具体时间不重要
Jake: The specific time mentioned above isn't important.
Jake:时间线比较重要
Jake: The timeline is more important.
Jake:就是不要那么具体
Jake: It doesn't have to be that specific.
Jake:差个5分钟没关系
Jake: Being off by 5 minutes is fine.
Jake:没连上
Jake: It's not connected.
Shure: 你这是室内设计对吧
Shure: You're talking about interior design, right?
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Jake:插电了有电吗
Jake: Plug it in, does it have power?
Jake:没电而这上有电呢
Jake: No power, but there's power here.
Jake:互相有电
Jake: They have power for each other.
Jake:哎呦呦没电了话
Jake: Oh no, no power.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake:呃就是他出不了图
Jake: Uh, it can't display the images.
Shure: 这歌单成分太复杂了只能说
Shure: This playlist is just too complicated, that's all I can say.
Lucia: 是吗
Lucia: Really?
Katrina:  这这个也没倒是吗
Katrina: This one didn't fall either, right?
Jake:对这个没倒
Jake: Yeah, this one didn't fall.
Jake:中午没倒
Jake: It didn't fall at noon.
Alice:是卫生纸
Alice: It's toilet paper.
Jake:哎饿两个小时再坐
Jake: Yeah, wait two more hours to sit.
Jake:对妥妥的坐
Jake: Yeah, sit comfortably.
Jake:你命个名
Jake: You name it.
Jake:然后大家跟你对个齐
Jake: Then everyone aligns with you.
Jake:对齐时间
Jake: Align the time.
Jake:然后又可以去玩
Jake: Then we can play again.
Jake:嗯充上就行
Jake: Yeah, just charge it.
Jake:因为太因为没电是吧
Jake: Because, because there's no power, right?
Lucia: 啊谢谢
Lucia: Ah, thank you.
Jake:现在多low啊
Jake: It's so low now.
Jake:太low啊
Jake: So low.
Jake:10% 坐一会吧
Jake: 10%, let's sit for a while.
Jake:嘿你这个挺好
Jake: Hey, this is pretty good.
Jake:掌握了精髓
Jake: You've grasped the essence.
Jake:在画画
Jake: Drawing.
Lucia: 不我在想
Lucia: No, I'm thinking.
Lucia: 我怎样能把那个他
Lucia: How can I make that room look better?
Lucia: 这个房间设计的更好看一点
Lucia: Design it to look a bit nicer.
Jake:我去你这个是啥呀
Jake: Whoa, what is this?
Alice:花
Alice: Flowers.
Jake:这什么材料呢
Jake: What material is this?
Lucia: 如果是1.5乘
Lucia: If it’s 1.5 by...
Alice:卫生纸
Alice: Toilet paper.
Jake:我靠
Jake: Oh my god.
Lucia: 哇好好看
Lucia: Wow, it looks so good.
Alice:哈哈哈没有
Alice: Hahaha, no I haven't.
Lucia: 你已经又上了一层颜色
Lucia: You've added another layer of color.
Jake:确实挺牛逼
Jake: It's really impressive.
Lucia: 这是1*2米
Lucia: This is 1 by 2 meters.
Jake:不给我看是不
Jake: You’re not going to show me, are you?
Jake:为什么呢
Jake: Why not?
Lucia: 没有我正在想
Lucia: No, I'm thinking.
Lucia: 我那个做成什么样的比例比较好
Lucia: What proportion should I make that?
Lucia: 我打算拿一个渔网把它挂一下
Lucia: I'm planning to hang it up with a fishing net.
Alice:应该拿个便宜点的眼影
Alice: Should get a cheaper color.
Jake:你知道如果没有你们我现在是什么样
Jake: You know, if it weren't for you guys, do you know what I'd be like right now?
Alice:有点心疼
Alice: It makes me a bit sad.
Tasha:哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahahaha.
Katrina: 你拿眼影花吗？
Alice:对我没有别的
Alice:干枯玫瑰
Jake:六六台眼镜
Jake: Six six glasses.
Alice:用点不常用的颜色
Alice: Use some less common colors.
Alice:要不然我心疼
Alice: Otherwise, it makes me sad.
Tasha: 还好不常用
Tasha: It's okay, they're not used often.
Alice:还可以吧
Alice: It's still okay.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Mm.
Alice:干枯玫瑰色
Jake:有了有了
Jake: Got it, got it.
Jake:有了可以用
Jake: Got it, can use it.
Jake:当然可以用
Jake: Of course we can use it.
Jake:这触摸板确实不太灵敏
Jake: This touchpad isn't very responsive.
Jake:苹果农贸
Jake: Apple market.
Jake:嗯苹果应该能到
Jake: Yeah, Apple should be able to arrive.
Jake:我不知道苹果
Jake: I don't know, Apple.
Jake:他不一定有苹果
Jake: He might not have an Apple.
Jake:你的苹果没有那个
Jake: Your Apple doesn't have that.
Jake:那那个口
Jake: That port.
Alice:OK
Jake:没有SD口
Jake: No SD port.
Jake:那就可以倒
Jake: Then it can be transferred.
Jake:那你要有SD也要有USB
Jake: You need both an SD and a USB port.
Alice:看
Tasha: 以假乱真
Tasha: Looks so real.
Jake:那那呃
Jake: Umm...
Lucia: 哇完美融入
Lucia: Wow, perfectly integrated.
Alice:哈哈哈
Jake:共15台你三三三一人5台也行
Jake: There are 15 units, you can split them up, 5 each.
Lucia: 啊真的好完美融入
Lucia: Ah, it really is perfectly integrated.
Lucia: 可以看一下吗
Lucia: Can I take a look?
Lucia: 啊不算
Lucia: Ah, never mind.
Lucia: 你已经插进去了
Lucia: You've already inserted it.
Alice:无所谓拿着看吧
Alice: It's alright, just take a look.
Lucia: 哈哈我害怕把它碰
Lucia: Haha, I'm afraid of touching it.
Alice:会不啊
Lucia: 哇真的很完美融入
Lucia: Wow, really perfectly integrated.
Lucia: 好看好看
Lucia: Looks good, looks good.
Jake:行再来一台吧
Jake: Alright, let's get another one.
Alice: 嗯
Alice: Hmm.
Jake:呃不是还有一个
Jake: Uh, isn't there one more?
Katrina:  是的
Katrina: Yes.
Jake:再来一个硬盘呗
Jake: Let's get another hard drive.
Jake:Wu也不是UR了吧
Jake: Wu is no longer UR, right?
Jake:Wu能快一点吧
Jake: Wu can be faster, right?
Jake:也不一定
Jake: Not necessarily.
Jake:说实话
Jake: To be honest.
Jake:不不不就就就三台硬盘
Jake: No, no, just three hard drives.
Jake:就这样吧就这样吧
Jake: That's it, that's it.
Jake:确实确实
Jake: Indeed, indeed.
Jake:多歇一会也行
Jake: We can rest a bit more.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Alice:是不是很
Jake:保安都删了
Jake: Security deleted everything.
Jake:保安你看一眼视频差不多对不对
Jake: Security, just take a look at the video, right?
Jake:一般我们看这个就是大小对不对
Jake: Usually, we check the size, right?
Jake:对了就没问题
Jake: If it's right, then no problem.
Jake:就是分屏
Jake: It's split screen.
Jake:一般我你看都全是分屏
Jake: Usually, you see, it's all split screen.
Jake:12个头对 12个屏
Jake: 12 cameras, right, 12 screens.
Jake:好然后再装回去
Jake: Okay, then put it back.
Jake:装回到这个里边
Jake: Put it back inside here.
Jake:一个屏幕四个屏
Jake: One screen, four screens.
Jake:查看来熟悉一下
Jake: Check it out and get familiar with it.
Jake:你们有几个人一起一场
Jake: How many of you were together in one session?
Jake:那个魔力大变
Jake: That big magic change.
Jake:今天早上10个
Jake: This morning, 10 people.
Shure: 10个好像将近10个
Shure: 10 people, seems like almost 10.
Jake:你第几个
Jake: Which number were you?
Shure: 我第
Shure: I was...
Shure: 不是谁谁自告奋勇
Shure: It wasn't anyone volunteering.
Shure: 就是谁先来
Shure: Just whoever came first.
Jake:你是好奋友
Jake: You were brave.
Shure: 我第二个
Shure: I was second.
Shure: 我第一个
Shure: I was first.
Jake:牛逼
Jake: Impressive.
Shure: 没没没答上
Shure: No, no, I didn't answer it.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Shure: 然后我后面的同学
Shure: Then my classmate after me.
Shure: 呃就是我女朋友
Shure: Uh, my girlfriend.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Shure: 她电脑突然放不出来了
Shure: Her computer suddenly stopped working.
Shure: 然后又借她电脑用一下
Shure: Then I borrowed her computer for a bit.
Jake:哦你要帮帮那个忙
Jake: Oh, you had to help with that.
Shure: 然后所以就10点半正好答完
Shure: So I finished right at 10:30.
Jake:所以最后他们10个人的话结束
Jake: So, in the end, they finished with 10 people.
Jake:没有结束
Jake: Or not finished.
Shure: 12点多
Shure: Around 12 o'clock.
Shure: 9点到12点
Shure: From 9 to 12.
Jake:路上就是有一些我
Jake: On the way, I was...
Jake:我用就是我手忙脚乱的导出来了
Jake: I was in a hurry, but I managed to export it.
Jake:在那个硬盘里
Jake: It's on the hard drive.
Jake:我把硬盘给你们
Jake: I'll give you the hard drive.
Jake:然后还是把硬盘给青春
Jake: Or I'll give the hard drive to Qingchun.
Jake:你你你你先整别的吧
Jake: You, you, you work on something else first.
Jake:USB卡比较隔热就完事了
Jake: The USB card is more insulated, and that's it.
Jake:你可以给他隔热化
Jake: You can give it insulation.
Jake:运营也行
Jake: Operations are fine too.
Jake:金猪帮我
Jake: Jin Zhu, help me.
Jake:把我的水给我
Jake: Get me my water.
Jake:帮忙收点数据吧
Jake: Can you help collect some data?
Shure: 什么数据
Shure: What data?
Jake:多多多看看昨天买的东西
Jake: Take a look at what we bought yesterday.
Shure: 好的
Shure: Okay.
Jake:一些毫无逻辑的行为
Jake: Some completely illogical actions.
Jake:硬加一些QA
Jake: Force some QA in.
Jake:好吧你你就出题
Jake: Alright, you come up with the questions.
Jake:好吧你现在就哈哈哈
Jake: Okay, now you just go hahaha.
Shure: 为什么我们要买这些东西
Shure: Why did we buy these things?
Shure: 白糖是干什么的
Shure: What is the sugar for?
Shure: 玉米淀粉又是干什么
Shure: And what about the cornstarch?